pouvait ce merveilleux pays il ya 40 ans
qui rayonnait à travers le monde
aujourd'hui on est devenue une province
de vulgaires province européenne nous
avons perdu tout ou le contrôle de notre
souveraineté monétaire financière mêmes
industriels et donc c'est une raison
pour laquelle je suis là devant la
banque de france avait accompagné d'un
drapeau français
effectivement sur le plan monétaire déjà
c'était pas c'était pas très bon et on
s'est aperçu que sur le plan sanitaire
l'europe a été encore une fois une
catastrophe et malheureusement
nous repartons encore de encore plus mal
et je crains que malheureusement la
politique de prêt fait par la bce n'aura
aucune efficacité
ces symboles souveraineté monétaire
c'est un élément très important de la
souveraineté d'un pays pouvoir maîtriser
sa monnaie pouvoir maîtriser les taux
d'intérêt de sa monnaie ses clés en fait
et
on a abandonné ses souveraineté ce
pouvoir donner à bruxelles à la banque
centrale européenne qui n'est là en fait
que pour servir les intérêts des 1%
parce que la banque centrale européenne
toutes les décisions qu'elle prend
qu'elle apprécie de leur année c'était
uniquement pour soutenir les marchés
financiers et non pas l'économie